cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com we have this week from Scott
Adams this story as Dave says is wild
Scott Adams tweeted July 1st 2020. if
Biden is elected there's a good chance
he will be dead within the year
Republicans will be hunted police will
stand down
on September 30th Josh Krueger says the
Dilbert dude is like Nostradamus look at
this prediction from 2020 wow Eerie
making fun of Scott Adams for uh having
made that point and then we have this
story from timcast.com journalists shot
seven times in Philadelphia home
Josh Krueger was killed in his home on
Monday
oh that's crazy so this is actually what
this is uh
this was it was killed today is that it
I thought it was uh 1am jeez wow so this
guy
who uh was just mocking Scott Adams over
his prediction about the stuff was shot
and killed in his own home I think the
news is that there was no sign of a
break-in
he had mocked and argued critic
expressing concern of a rising crime in
Philadelphia yeah he made fun of people
who
um weren't taking covet seriously and he
said covet is more of a serious threat
than the urban violence that's happening
all throughout the United States and he
was pretty much ridiculing a lot of
people who were taking it seriously as I
think if you live in a major city you
should be taking uh you know survival
and uh and personal protection very
seriously I think you might want to
consider not being there but let's uh
here's one too he says look it's that
Lawless land of liberals in Philly where
shootings are dropping to levels not
seen in years here's another one bro
speak for your block not mine it isn't
ruined the city isn't ruined and just
because Larry krasner keeps winning in
landslides doesn't mean Philly is a heap
of cinders and Ash no matter how much
people say like the rest of this country
we are dealing with upticks in crime the
crazy thing is yo I saw these tweets
when I I don't know when he posted this
one but I remember seeing people between
us before he died yeah it's not too long
I think they were in August yeah right I
remember when these tweets were going on
people were saying like are you crazy
like you're not considering what the
people need this dude was killed in his
own home in Baltimore we had the story
of that Tech CEO who was found beaten to
death on her roof by a guy who only a
few days earlier had tortured a couple
he broke broke into their house tied
them up raped the woman set them both on
fire police knew he did it and they said
nothing and then he killed again and
then they came and said okay okay this
is getting serious these are the things
that are happening in our cities don't
get me wrong these things happen crime
happens all the stuff happens but it is
just
I don't know what you'd call it shocking
coincidence or whatever that this guy
has been defending the positions the
Democrats have taken that have led to
this increase in crime he has mocked
people who feared that you would be
seriously harmed by police standing down
and he lost his life dude do you know
how many people I knew at the height of
kovid in the summer of love when
everybody was rampaging through
everything in there ransacking all the
streets and all of that how many
Hollywood liberals that I knew that were
all day long for the previous five years
ranting and raving about gun rights who
were calling me and other people that I
knew on where where can we buy guns yeah
I have a friend who would never want me
to be named but like a big time
celebrity person uh who I knew you know
could get guns right and everybody was
trying to I almost it doesn't even
matter the gender of this person but uh
they were they were inundated with the
amount of people because when push comes
to shove you know basic you know it's uh
a conservative is just a liberal mug by
reality I think this guy actually had a
gun is that possible in Philly or is it
yeah no he said in another Twitter
thread that he had a gun and a guy had
previously broken into his house and he
didn't get the gun he figured out
another way of escalating it even though
the guy was standing in his bedroom or
something yeah this is where the story
gets a little deeper like on face style
you're like uh oh random violence maybe
but in reality this guy has had a
history with drugs um drug abuse and he
if like what they were just saying he at
some point in April of this year or some
other year had woke up and a guy was in
his room and he's like what are you
doing here some guy he used to know how
did he get in I must have given him a
key maybe he didn't even remember giving
a guy a key to his house so this is the
guy who at 1 30 in the morning with no
sign of a break-in gets shot in his own
apartment like who are those people how
did they get in if there's no breaking
and I don't know that the no break-in is
definitely confirmed did you confirm
that or not I have no I don't know I
just didn't see any signs of a break and
no one mentioned any kind of breaking
and entering so 1 30 in the morning got
shot seven times in his own room has a
history of giving his key out to people
and not remembering it
and history that's just an excuse
because it happened and he didn't want
to come out and be like yeah but
conservatives I gotta say when David
Hogg said when they were getting rid of
the Mask mandates and he says yeah but I
I don't I don't want to take it off
because some people think I'm a
republican yeah like these are the
people who would rather allow someone to
break into their home and kill them than
admit conservatives were right he
actually tweeted that he was ready to
die or some something like I guess I'll
die then or some something like who
David uh no Josh Krueger I don't know I
I glanced at it earlier didn't save the
location of a tweet but if you scroll
down his feed maybe it's there it's
tough to talk about because the guy did
just die so we gotta be really a little
sensitive about that's the thing you
know uh so Mike cernovich had some
tweets out recently about how if uh
Biden wins he says have you had the talk
something about have you had the talk
with your family about how you'll be
framed for a crime so they can kill you
or whatever and I'm like a bit
aggressive a bit aggressive I I don't
completely I I should I don't disagree
with with Mike just a bit aggressive and
my response was people don't know don't
understand what happens to a country
when they begin arresting their
political opposition and lawyers
so
I think there's a normalcy bias people
don't want to believe it and that's why
I like to do the time travel test go
back insert x amount of years and tell
people everything that happened today
they won't believe you you go back six
years and say Donald Trump will be
indicted they'll go after his lawyers
they'll indict his lawyers they'll start
issuing fines in the 200 Grand on
lawyers who argued on his behalf in the
election people are going to be like
shut up that'll never happen in this
country mention January 6 to someone six
seven years ago and they're gonna be
like oh shut up that won't happen that's
crazy yeah there's a fire we are the
viral video of the mayor of Chicago in
72. oh yeah so we played it on my
shoulder he was saying that looters you
shoot looters to kill them and or
arsonists you shoot them to kill looters
you shoot to maim and this is just the
governor or the governor he was he was
the mayor of Mayor Chicago think about
how that daily has fallen no it was uh
someone can grab his name I think it was
the mayor in about 72. you guys remember
we'll get it yeah um but it's a great
video it's like you're watching a
competent executive be like I'll defend
the Free People of my city the people
who are doing it right instead of
defending the looters and the arsonists
and everyone else and also saying in
essence
we believe we live in a society talk
about George Costanza like we either
live in a society or we don't but this
is why I am optimistic
look man yeah it was mayor Daly it was
mayor Daly 1968 wow because I'm pretty
sure because the dailies run right in
Chicago forever but uh uh look man
when they're aborting their kids when
they're sterilizing their kids when they
would rather there'll be none of them
left they won't exactly they won't
defend themselves they won't advocate
for the defense and they will advocate
for the machine that hates them I'm just
like if you got a guy who says no guns
no guns oh someone broke into my house
don't worry I still don't need guns it's
like well this dude is not likely to
have kids and I'm not you gotta zoom out
it's never it's it's not about what one
person does or doesn't do it's about
what most people do and even to tiny
tiny degrees if
50.01 of liberals engage in behaviors
that result in them having no kids
they're they're gonna slowly cease to
exist and their ideology will go along
with them I hope but communism's been
around for a long time yeah and also if
you factor in like you know China using
Tick Tock to brainwash a generation of
Americans it's not as simple as just
pure like like numbers in terms of I
think it's giving birth it's there's a
there is an ideological war being waged
but children that are that are
converting right I I agree but I do
think it's I still think having kids is
10 to 100 times more impactful than
social manipulation social manipulation
plays a large role but there's inverse
social uh reaction right so uh
Libertarians conservatives post-liberals
coming out and saying no to this stuff
in school no to tick tock get your kids
off social media homeschool your kids
that counter Force to a certain degree
will negate the effect of China or
whatever social manipulation we're
experiencing you add to that mix they're
literally advocating for things that put
their lives in danger or inhibit them
from having children
I think in 20 years you got a two to one
Republican Advantage I hope you're right
man how often do you Dole out white
pills these days that I've been saying
this thing for a couple years and people
argue that I'm wrong and I'm like
because they make the point you made and
I'm like I agree they're trying to
indoctrinate kids but when you look at
what Florida did with the books saying
like when DeSantis did that press
conference where he's like look at these
books look at what was in these books
Nikki freed said Rhonda Santa's posting
butt plug porn and it's like he's
criticizing you uh that right there as a
governor exposing this and giving them
no recourse because all she could do is
admit it that's waking people up
like yes there are a lot of
conservatives it's funny when they come
to Tim cast iron Studios and they're
like they say oh my kids are going to
college next time I'm like which one and
they're like oh NYU and I'm like are you
insane yeah like do you watch the show
you're about to be maybe University of
Chicago that's pretty much it that's
pretty much it you guys a couple others
could you talk publicly about how you
guys want to raise the kids
in terms of schooling yeah stuff like
that you know it's funny not really but
I would say just sort of generally
speaking I mean first up we're in
Florida where we have really some of the
best public schools in the United States
and it's ironic because you know 20
years ago when Florida was thought of as
The Golden Girls and this is where
everyone goes to retire and there's no
income tax there were bad schools here
because older people didn't want to put
money towards it and there just wasn't
an income tax in the first place now we
have basically the best schools in the
nation I don't my I mean just because of
my uh public nature I don't think we'll
send them to public school but but
regardless the idea that you just hand
your kid off to some state employee and
that they could call your son by the
opposite gender name they can make up a
name and then hide it from you and the
whole machine was like DeSantis
is the bad guy for fighting this is so
bananas here's thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows elusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time